à quelques jours de l'ouverture du
festival de cannes la sélection
française aura écarté l'un des très gros
succès de ces derniers jours un film
magique et déjà attiré plus d'un million
de spectateurs en une semaine mais qui
semble-t-il n'a pas su plaire au jury
chargé de nommer les longs métrages qui
porteront les couleurs françaises le
fabuleux destin d'amélie poulain
réalisé par jean pierre jeunet cumule
tous les bonheurs le talent la légèreté
une oeuvre généreuse optimiste encensé
par la critique et par le public
michel périer béatrice mende un sourire
qui en dit long et un regard espiègle
audrey tautou porte sur son visage une
humeur coquine
le film de jean pierre jeunet tombe dans
l'escarcelle ou plutôt le panthéon des
oeuvres qui bouscule de cinéma français
qui vivent le point commun c'est un
million deux cent mille entrées le film
réalise une première semaine
ébouriffante
c'est tout le monde se reconnaît dans
cette amélie qui est serveuse dans un
bar de montmartre et qui décide un beau
jour de faire le bien autour d'elle
quelqu'un qui comme un trésor
comment je vais revoir un mini plein
revoir pourquoi j'ai bien aimé ses pages
un petit peu énervé je vais le voir mon
avis sur une bonne humeur on me sort
tiens je vais le revoir puisqu'il est
génial qu'il n'y ait aucune baisse
sur la deuxième semaine c'est à dire un
nouveau mercredi soir on était complet
sur les deux séances du soir jeudi soir
pareil
donc je vois là c'est ça qui fait qu'ils
laissent penser que c'est quand même
assez exceptionnel
la presse pointe du doigt ce phénomène
les publics c'est fonctionner le bouche
à oreille un engouement qui surprend le
réalisateur d'agia de revient d'une
tournée en province j'ai fait une
dizaine de villes et de voir les sables
debout tellement heureuse c'est presque
ça se passe a fait peur c'est que sait
on du matin de quoi le qu'on parle de
quoi en qu'est-ce qu'on a touché pour
que ça ça touchés bouleversés autant
certaines personnes c'est étonnant
malgré ce succès amélie n'est pas en
compétition à cannes c'est mathieu
kassovitz qui met le feu aux poudres il
déclare que le fabuleux destin aurait pu
remporter la palme d'or un bémol à la
belle histoire que le film est en train
de vivre
c'est l'un des premiers films deuxième
film on a vu en sélection et comme vous
le savez la tradition veut qu'on voit à
environ 70 80 films français et qu'on
les voit en janvier février mars avril
et que une fois qu'on a tout vu on fait
notre choix
on a souhaité attendre un petit peu de
voir le reste de la sélection des
propositions françaises pour nous
décider et ont préféré sortir en tout
cas amélie zone des couleurs au cinéma
français est consacré pour la première
fois par la bible hollywoodienne le
magazine variéty qui salue le fabuleux
savoir faire français qui va s'en
occuper